Hello everybody. This is Dr. Kevin Conner. So this is going to be a video about why we believe and why we love doing these
Conference Zoom calls, a matter of fact, I'm doing this video on a conference Zoom call
So it's the same platform that we use for keeping in touch with our patients and that's the whole key to this
We believe that we should really keep in touch with our patients
I had somebody in the day asked, tell me, hey, I think it's really great that you keep in touch with your past patients
By doing these weekly Zoom calls, this is just phenomenal. I've never seen this in the industry, in any medical field,
whatsoever. It's really great. And I was taken back by their comment because they said, keep in touch with past patients.
And I said, quite honestly, I never thought of it that way. We don't keep in touch with past patients.
If you become a patient of ours, you are a current patient. We don't have any past patients.
So current patients have that access to us, you know, constantly.
And how we stay in communication with them is a few different platforms.
This video is going to be on our conference calls. I'm going to make another video on our Facebook group platform where you have basically 24
7 access to us. This is weekly access to both Dr. Haller and I and we set this up because we are constantly learning. We're constantly striving for new data.
We're constantly fighting new genetic pieces to cancer. We're constantly fighting new
possible remedies. And how do we keep in contact with people? Because I don't want somebody who came to me six months ago, not know about this new thing that we just discovered in a new research paper that just got published last week.
And so that's why we set these up so that we could give you the latest, greatest information constantly on a weekly basis.
So that you're not missing out. So if there's something that's going to be really good for your colon cancer, that a study just got published last week, that you're going to hear about it.
And we're going to be able to bring that information to you without having to try to find everybody who has colon cancer and our database and call them, you have cuts that access to us.
So that's the whole thing because the biggest struggle that I think people have when they go to the doctor is that they go to the doctor, they the traditional scenario is you go to the doctor, you get your care, you leave.
And if you want to talk to the doctor again or talk to a staff member or a team member, it becomes difficult. You have to schedule an appointment to appointments can be two to three months out.
And you feel all alone. And there's no way that you could absorb all that information that you needed in a 20 minute visit or a two day visit or going to Mexico and people people confused, well, how come your program is only a two day program and I go to Mexico or something, and it's a three week program.
Well, I covered that in other other videos, but I don't believe you could get healed from cancer in three weeks.
And it has got to be a lifetime thing. And our biggest thing that makes us different is that number one, you go home with a quid.
So you're not getting right therapy for three weeks and PMF and hyperbaric and IV vitamin C and such and then think that you're cured. I mean, this has got to be a lifelong thing.
So you're going home with a right that you're using every night, but the other thing that makes us different is that you are in contact with us forever.
So this, these zoom calls that we're talking about here, these zoom conference calls, we do these weekly, so many times more than once a week, so that you could be in contact with us forever.
So that you never feel alone, you never feel like you're an island, you'd ever feel like, and I'd understand that hopefully you have a support team, a spouse and a family that are loving you and taking care of you, but many times you need that professional support. And that's what this is all about. And that's really what makes us different.
So we never want anybody to feel like they're disconnected.
And that is to me, the greatest degree of problems in health care, it used to be Marcus Welby would make house calls, what we still make house calls.
And that's a big piece of our program too, if you need us to come to your house, we'll come to your house.
And I think that's what we're trying to bring back, is that personalized medicine, that's not only personalized to what your needs are with genetic testing, it's specific kadeziology testing, so we're going to get specific and build a program that a protocol around you, but we're going to stay in contact with you, you become a part of our family and all of our patients feel, I really do believe that they feel connected and loved and cared for.
And, you know, we go home and we literally pray for our patients constantly, so that is that that that communication connection is the key.
So that's why we decided, well, how can we do this? How can we, how can we make this happen? And that's where these weekly calls came into being quite some time ago.
So we do these weekly calls exactly how it set up, so we have people literally from all around the world that are on our calls on a weekly basis.
And from our Facebook page, you are given a zoom link, so we use the product zoom, which is simply just a webinar type based.
Program that exists and it works real nice and if they ever go away, we'll use something else prior to that we use Skype, so the zoom call platform gives us a really a benefit so we can have an endless amount of people on the conference call.
I can mute everybody while while I or Dr. Hallermann do our little weekly information session to begin with and we open it up for questions and anybody can ask whatever questions they want. They typically these typically last between 30 and 30 minutes and an hour to half.
And they look similar to this, they look similar to exactly what you're watching right now, because this is the zoom call platform that we're doing this on.
And I'll have a topic or Dr. Hallermann would have a topic. This was my topic just a couple of weeks ago, cancer and emotional scars where I went over about 20 minutes of some new data that I've been studying or something that I just felt like God put on my heart that I needed to tell you.
And same thing with Dr. Hallermann and then we give that little lecture you could call it that it is it is.
Then opened up for questions and we answer questions that people have or emailed in during the week to so you always feel connected you always feel like your questions are answered.
And then after it's all done, we record that call so that conference call is recorded and it's put up on our Facebook page. So here was the one from last week. Here's Dr. Kelly's truth about fasting, which you did a little X was a fastie to the fastie mimicky diet and time restricted eating.
Here was mine from the week before about the emotions of cancer, so that then you don't have to be on the call. So I understand your life is busy and one of our foundational precepts in our care is we don't want you thinking about your cancer all the time.
And if you're doing really well, it's like I'm not going to go on the call, but it does give you the ability to access them.
And then they're posted on the Facebook page and then you could you could go on it and you can watch that video if you want to if that's a subject better than interest you or you do have questions you could jump on it live either way.
We want you to feel connection and feel like you're not alone. And that's what our purpose in the conference calls are. So we really want everybody to use them.
Most people do we have anywhere from just a maybe a dozen to several dozen people on each conference call. So it's not overwhelming.
Most people can get their questions in and we ask people if you have questions that maybe you don't want to pipe in. We ask that you email questions in it. You just tag them on the tagline of the email.
Zoom call question and we always get to those two. So your questions will be answered and you feel like you're you're moving to the right direction and that you're always got your hand held.
So hopefully this helps and we'll have another video about the Facebook page and how to use that. Thanks very much.